here's to honor
among thieves we almost pulled it off my
friends are eating take it slow despite
what everybody thought - they're gonna
blame us for the whole thing we're the
patsies
don't forget mmm we're the bad guys
please don't make a nice
we've all heard the stories of Samson
leveling a temple with a single push for
the Philistine weapon of mass
destruction named Goliath the next war
will be fought with these metahumans
please don't ours or theirs I want a
simple a task force of the most
dangerous people on the planet
okay never stand down made-up way y'all
jokers must be crazy this is the deal
you're going somewhere very bad look at
the pretty lights to do something
that'll get skilled you might want to
work on your team motivation thing you
heard of Phil Jackson yeah he's like the
gold standard ok triangle [ __ ]
ah hey the farm like hey lookie here
oh yeah London I can't wait to show you
my toys we're going to the swirling ring
of trash in the sky they woke in the
puck easy-peasy
don't make me shoot you biggest Boston
I've been in trillest
I'm a bigger problem when I go
forgive me for my wrongs I have just
begun
there's Owen cares
Jess in my bar but she came back of my
chair
from this point
forgive me for my wrongs I have just
begun no mercy ain't no mercy